it's a fact that a lot of people end up
in the same jobs that their parents have
and I think it's a lot to do with things
like conversations over the dinner table
or becoming familiar with the language
of that job and I guess kids wanting to
pursue what they know and what they know
is their parents occupations they're a
lot more likely to end up following a
similar path but I yet this makes some
occupations feel really sort of
exclusive to people that are on the
outside that people to people that
aren't from the real with the language
of how that job works and how you get
into it I think it's kind of a problem
for things like academic areas where if
your parents are professors maybe you'll
find it easier to become one too I'm not
sure my parents certainly are didn't
have any scientific background and
neither of them went on to university
but here I am doing a PhD in physics so
I'm certainly not really following in
the footsteps of my parents and I think
there's maybe two sides to it I think
some aspects of being the first in your
family to go to university are a little
bit hard things like just not knowing
how the system works like when I got to
university I had never even heard of a
PhD I had no idea how the progression
from one degree to another worked I had
no idea about how you sort of get a job
in academia I had no idea about even
what you're supposed to do once you get
to uni I've just sort of learnt that as
I've gone I
so certainly didn't know any science
until quite late in my life I was
probably quite a late starter I didn't
really know anything about science until
actually until high school definitely
and then told quite late high school I
didn't have as a kid any of those sort
of science toys that I see now I see
people giving their children these toys
that teach them coding or maths at a
really early age and I just look at that
and I think wow that's crazy like those
exist and I can't imagine what it would
have been like to be exposed to more
scientific ideas at a young age and to
even be exposed to the idea of being a
scientist as a child that would have
been really different for me and I don't
know how it would have changed the
outlook I have now because I think
there's actually benefits for being the
first in your family to do something for
example I've never felt any pressure to
take a certain path I would hate to feel
pressured into taking like it made us an
allure of some certain subject that
traditionally students feel a lot of
pressure from their parents to go into I
would sort of hate that I'm feel very
lucky to just be able to pursue what I
like it's got the challenge of me having
to convince my parents though of what
I'm doing because they don't really have
any idea of the path I'm taking so I
have to sort of explain it to them and
explain maybe why I think it's useful so
that could be hard like sometimes if I
call my mom during like when I've been a
student and I'll tell her that it's
really hard and a stress so she'll just
say why don't you drop out already
yeah are you gonna quit physics yet have
you had enough of it
and I just say no I'm gonna I'm gonna
stick in for a bit longer see how it
goes but I don't really have that person
that's been through it telling me you
know it'll get better it'll it'll be
this will be that so I've just got to
figure that out as I go I think through
this my parents are really just learnt
to trust me
to trust that I'm doing something that I
enjoy and and they're fine with that so
they've been supportive and that's great
one big benefit maybe that comes from
being sort of the first of my family to
be at uni is that I feel like I'm able
to think more outside of the box because
I have no idea what the box is so like
for example I've always done a lot of
sort of extra side projects or
extracurricular activities while
studying because I enjoy doing other
things and I never really had any idea
that I shouldn't be doing something else
whether it's making videos or doing
other science communication or going
into like business startup competitions
or anything else I feel like I feel like
maybe I wouldn't have done so many extra
things if I was trying to follow in
somebody else's footsteps if I wasn't
just walking my own path so to say when
I hear of people whose parents are both
professors and they're on track to be
one themselves I think wow that must be
such a different way of life to the one
I've experienced but I don't think there
is any real good or bad about being on
either side of this I think you still
need to form your own path regardless of
what your parents have done and if
they're an inspiration for you then
that's great
and if you want to do something totally
different from them I think I'd
encourage that as well